in this video i'm going to be going
through five tech side project ideas you
can start right now without writing any
lines of code if you're new to this
channel i'm a solutions marketer
graduate based in australia working at
aws
and in this video i'm going to be going
through these five side projects
i'll be talking about how to get started
how hard it is to get started
and also give you a personal rating out
of five because these were side projects
that i've done to varying degrees during
my time in university so these side
projects will also come in handy if
you're a student applying to tech
companies for non-technical roles
because employers look for people who
have a strong interest in tech
and si projects are a great way to
demonstrate that this is a video i wish
i had during my first year of university
so without further ado let's jump right
into it okay so idea number one is
starting a podcast
and this is a very very powerful one
because you might be asking me and you
might be wondering
well lucy don't i need to be an expert
in something related to tech to start a
tech podcast
but in reality most people who start a
podcast don't have much experience in
what they want to talk about
because they're initially interested in
the topic and they want to learn more
about it
but what they do is instead of talking
about the topic themselves at the start
they bring a subject matter experts onto
their show and the good thing about this
is for example if you start a podcast
related to
getting people into product management
so you interview people who
are senior product managers you bring
them on to the show become an active
listener and ask them about their
experiences
what's really helpful is that you're not
only gaining these experiences and
learning about them but you're also
sharing it to other students who are
interested in the same thing
so starting a podcast isn't as
intimidating as it might seem
so you start off by defining your niche
and then you gather equipment whether
you want to use your iphone microphone
or investing in an external microphone
and then you find guests for your
podcast so the best way to do this is to
reach out to people on linkedin by
sending a personalized message
and afterwards blocking out one or two
hours to record the podcast with the
guest either in person or
zoom editing the podcast using an audio
editor
and finally uploading it onto youtube
spotify or anchor.fm which helps you
distribute it across multiple channels
some potential features directions
include adding video to your podcast
monetizing it and seeking out brand
sponsorships
now side project idea number two is
starting a tech youtube channel which is
what you're watching right now
so i started this channel towards the
end of last year when i was doing intern
at aws
and it's been pretty fun so far it's
definitely had its fair share of
challenges
so for my first video it took me over 10
hours to make
and a lot of the time i feel like giving
up and just not making videos anymore
but it's been super worthwhile and i
feel like it's more like a long-term
investment but one thing i regret doing
is not starting this earlier so last
year i already received my grad offer
and already knew that i was going to be
at aws this year and there was just a
lot of certainty and i felt like i was
ready to start a channel but
in reality i think what you should do is
start when you're not ready when you
don't feel prepared when you don't have
the qualifications and you're not an
intern at a tech company and you want to
document your experience getting there
so document your journey share
experience with others because there's
so many other people going through the
same experience
and they will resonate a lot with their
content and it's something you can bring
up
during interviews when you talk about
your experiences creating tech videos
for students
another branch of youtube you can dive
into is making tutorials so anything
you've learned in your university
classes anything that stands out you can
teach that through short videos
and publish it onto youtube so very
similar to starting a podcast
you begin by defining your niche and
gathering equipment and then
brainstorming your video ideas
after that you record and edit your
videos and upload it onto youtube
some potential future directions include
monetizing it
in that case you need 1 000 subscribers
and 4 000 hours of watch time
you can also try to get brand
sponsorships and experiment by hosting
live streams tech side project id number
three
is forming a tech community now this is
one of my most favorite ones because
it's the one that
has really defined my university
experiences i think it's
one thing to join a community that
already exists but it's a whole new
thing
to create something from the ground up
and building that
bring together like-minded people to
share resources attend events
and having that community where you're
all working towards a similar goal
is just so rewarding during my time in
university i started a student society
with a couple of friends
it's called the unsw digital society and
during a one year period we held over 45
events
and most importantly we established
something that can sustain itself
indefinitely so even though my friends
and i so the co-founders were not part
of the society anymore we were able to
hand it over to other students who are
part of the organizing committee and so
they can continue on and keep making
impact on the student community
so studying a tech club involves a bit
of planning because you're not only
responsible for yourself and your own
content
but you're also responsible for others
and that involves having a very clear
vision of the club
after all the logistics and planning the
next step would be to gather a group of
people
and create a committee after that you'll
be setting up a community online whether
that be on facebook or meetup
or an instagram page and then launching
your first event you can tailor the rest
of your events based on the feedback you
receive
and make sure you promote your events
through word of mouth and different
channels
potential future directions include
expanding out to different audiences
creating a mentoring program and even
creating custom merchandise
so side project idea number four is case
competitions or hackathons
and i think i'm cheating a little bit
with this one because it doesn't really
count as a side project per se
it's more like you bring a group of
people together and you participate in
something that helps you create a thai
project
when you have 24 hours to come up with a
solution with a team
really flesh it out come up with
prototypes you go through this whole
design thinking process and
at times even the implementation as well
and i think that it's a really good idea
for you to participate in
a lot of different hackathons because
not only do you get to develop your
communication skills and teamwork skills
but there's also a possibility that the
idea that you come up with during the
hackathon is something that you want to
work on in the future as well so to join
hackathons it's actually very easy
because these days many of the
hackathons are online
and you don't have to go to a physical
location now to compete so step one is
to find the hackathon you want to
participate in
step two is to form the group make sure
you have different skill sets in the
team
and step three is to participate in the
competition if you feel like the
hackathon idea has really strong
potential you could turn it into a slide
project
or even one day host your own hackathon
the final side project idea is creating
a personal website using a website
builder and you can disagree with me in
the comments if you want
but my personal opinion on this is that
personal websites are pretty overrated i
think in the past it was pretty common
for a lot of people to have their own
personal website
um and they can set it up have like
these cool themes and everything like
that
um but i think nowadays there is just so
much reach
in platforms such as linkedin youtube
and instagram
i think as a student if you're
interested in ux design um anything
related to
photography or anything art related it's
definitely helpful to have a
personal website because that's where
you create your own portfolio
and you can showcase that but i think if
you apply to any other role
i don't really see the point in having a
personal website if you can just
use linkedin to display all experiences
document your journey onto youtube
share your photos onto instagram instead
of posting it onto
your personal website i see a lot more
value in that because companies and
students they can reach you in a more
effective way so
taking youtube for example youtube is
the world's second largest search engine
which means if you publish a video going
like my journey interning at
this company and you document that
experience it's much easier for someone
to find it compared to if you just
uploaded it onto your personal website
so that's just my personal opinion on
this
but i think it's still very worthwhile
to have a personal website and that's
why i decided to mention this
idea at the very end i would recommend
focusing on the other four
and if you have time you can create a
personal website and
sort of link everything together with
that
thanks so much for watching i hope you
got something out of it please give this
video a like and subscribe for more tech
career and student advice bye for now